[MUSIC PLAYING]
[TYPING]
Hi, my name is Billur Sorguc.
I'm working as a senior
quality assurance engineer
at Monitise, Istanbul, Turkey.
Exploratory test is defined as
an unscripted test approach.
Usually we manage
our test process
based on documented
and preplanned steps.
However, in
exploratory testing, we
do test planning, design, and
execution all at the same time.
In exploratory
testing, the first step
is gathering different
people from other departments
who have not been
involved in the project.
For Monitise, this means the
business analysts, developers,
designers, project managers,
marketers, and others.
The key point is that we never
provide a specific scenario
or use case.
They need to create
their own scenarios
based on what they
would do as an end user
while using the
app in real time.
Instead, we just
say, this app is for,
for example, doing wire
transfer or something.
We just say what
that app is for,
and we're going to let
them to discover the app
and explore the
flow by themselves.
And next we choose
the right devices.
Doing the exploratory
testing on devices
with different operating
systems, different screen
resolutions, densities, screen
sizes, and operating system
versions provide good coverage
for a two-hour test session.
Afterwards, we give these
test devices, as well as
the Post-Its, to the
testers we have gathered.
And we want them to categorize
the issues they find and note
them on the Post-Its with
the corresponding color.
For example, if it's a bug,
they use the red Post-Its.
If it's an enhancement,
they use the green ones.
And if it's a new idea or any
suggestion about the usability,
they use the yellow ones.
During this two-hour
test session,
our test users explore
the functions, the flow,
and they take notes
on the Post-Its
about the issues they find.
They understand
the business model
and give feedbacks
about usability
or any other experience
that an end user
can face while using the app.
The issues,
suggestions, new ideas,
and feedbacks from this
brainstorming session
are saved and shared
with the project team.
The project team
prioritizes the list
and starts working on
those subjects afterwards.
The issues,
suggestions, new ideas,
and feedbacks from this
brainstorming session
are saved and shared
with the project team.
The project team
prioritizes the list
and starts working on
those subjects afterwards.
[MUSIC PLAYING]